et là dans les premières mesures qu'a
annoncé vendredi Gabriel hatal est-ce
que pour vous ça va dans le bon sens
mais alors c'est un changement complet
c'est comme quand le président de la
République dit on interdit le glyphosate
puis après on laisse l'Europe le le
remettre sans se mouiller enfin je veux
dire de la même manière sur les
NC qui avait dit à l'époque qu'il
fallait qui avait dit à l'époque qu'il
fallait pas faire ça Stéphane Lefol de
gauche écolo quand je porte l'
grroécologie mais je sais qu'il y a des
choses qu'on ne fait pas on fait pas
faire des zigzags à l'agriculture on
essaie d'avoir un cap faut baisser
l'utilisation des phytosanitaires
j'avais fait adopter les certificats
d'économie de phytosanitaire qui ont été
supprimés dans le cadre de cette fameuse
loi égalim et c'est une erreur parce
qu'on aurait dû travailler depuis
longtemps sur la manière dont on réduit
mais en même temps qu'on réduit les
phytosanitaires et la chimie on cherche
des alternatives aujourd'hui à chaque
fois qu'on supprime une molécule on dit
mais il y a pas d'autres molécules en
face ben non ça c'est sûr c'est pas une
molécule pour une a parce que c'est ce
que disent les agriculurs il y a pas de
solution on interdit il y a pas de
solution mais pourquoi parce que
personne n'a jamais cherché de solution
moi je sais très bien que l'objectif
qu'on avait fixé de baisse de 30 % des
phytosanitaires on pouvait tout à fait
l'atteindre tout à fait l'atteindre si
c'était estce que dans l'état actuel de
l'agriculture il faut les interdire ces
pesticides ou on n pas les moyens pour
le moment les CEPP quel était l'objectif
c'était de dire que on baissait les
ventes de phyo en chimie de 30 % en 5
ans et que si au bout de 5 ans il y
avait pas eu la baisse de 30 % on avait
une taxe qui s'appliquait pour pouvoir
engager des processus on savait très
bien qu'on pouvait sur la base de ce
qu'avait été les fermes défis et les
expérientations qui étaient faites
baisser de 30 % la totalité
d'utilisation des
phytosanitaires